try to clean it up [__] core
and not be corrupt and like profit off
of it that might be the most effective
method quickly you're just like
literally every point that you just made
is impossible impossible
just just say it
here's some uh classic irony there's a
man
who opened up a store to sell heroin and
cocaine right in Vancouver he was trying
to give people access to clean drugs
because it's legal there you could sell
it over there no oh the day after he
opened he got arrested this guy's dumb
huh
but he was trying to his his intentions
were to give people access to clean
drugs to help them kind of get off and
stuff like that and challenge Canadian
drug laws because you know there's a lot
of uh drugs that are like especially in
Vancouver there's an area where a lot of
drugs are [__] um mixed with like
Fentanyl and like other things like that
yeah so like he's trying to prevent
people oding and stuff like that but in
obviously a stroke of irony he actually
just died of an overdose as well oh [__]
man you're not supposed to get high off
your own Supply man he dumb she's dumb
he makes a lot of bad decisions he was
the man who opened the first store in
Canada openly selling tested heroin
cocaine and MDMA oh because he was doing
all the testing yeah that's why he was
yeah personally through his own body
he's all like it's like a chef taking
the spoon the daddies was really good
[__] yo this one's pure this one's pure
yeah dude uh and he had a bad batch he
ended up dying uh off of a fentanyl
overdose oh my God what the [__] no he
didn't test his own [__] I thought the
whole point is that he was making it so
it doesn't have family he was closed
down you know what I mean because like
he tried to open up the scene but then
he was closed down and then he relapsed
into his own you know prior addictions
and stuff like that and ended up getting
a bad batch of something which is damn
the irony to like what he was attempting
to do do you guys believe in that
solution which one you know the solution
that California does that a lot too it's
like oh yeah there's a bunch of people
that are doing drugs the way to help
them is to provide them with the tools
to do it cleanly right through the
government I think that helps one thing
like the ability to do clean drugs I
think that helps that problem but I just
because you know how they do like needle
exchange and then they'll even like give
them a place to do drugs and they'll
even like yeah I used to be a big
believer in it because the Scandinavian
countries did that they had like these
Havens or you can come in and do like
almost like morphine instead of heroin
so it's like pharmaceutical grade clean
needle so you don't Spread spread
disease yeah disease and stuff but then
to me the um
defend the new fentanyl like factor is
such a huge complication that I'm like
scared because like when I was a kid I
was like I did all these drugs and then
my parents told me not to do drugs and
I'm like oh if I have a kid I'll let
them explore because I think they just
got to get out of their system or
whatever but then now if I fence and all
and stuff like yeah and when they can't
have enough Supply don't buy it from
private sector you know how like a lot
of these Grow Ups they sell weed
actually to like this um like legit
dispensaries and stuff so if these clean
places don't have enough heroin they're
gonna start looking in private sector
heroin and how do you who's controlling
how much fentanyl is making into there
so I'm just so scared of such a lethal
dose now and now they're saying there's
a new one that's not even that's even
way crazier than fentanyl I don't know
what drug people are on but they show
all these like walk-throughs of uh skid
rows in other cities and there's people
that are just like like this
go like that or like like they're just
like this like their brains are just
fried schizophrenia brother no there's
like there's like schizophrenia brother
there's like 15 people just [__]
they're like this yeah dude and I'm like
how do you hold that position so long I
don't know what drug yeah gets them in
these positions and they're just [__]
leaning out they just need a rumble
roller
because it's hard it's it's a kind of
like a weird thing like I think at a
point you sound like such an
anti-humanitarian when you have some
epidemic like drug addiction yeah and
then you are trying to provide a way to
keep them alive at that State yeah
that's [__] so it's not you're not
trying to not
really get them out of it you're
thinking of like well how do I
perpetuate that without the diseases
without the diseases yeah without the
more how do we keep them from dying but
not living any better than that it
almost seems like a weird thing right I
also just think in general too that a
lot of people can't even handle weed you
know like so like the more accessible
that is for people I think you see
people just [__] up their lives kind of
by just with marijuana so imagine like a
higher grade of something that's gonna
take you out of your [__] body and
mind like I don't think that's good for
people for most people to do on a
regular basis
that's just my opinion so I think maybe
just less drugs might be a good idea we
all had a lot of fun with drugs for sure
but like you said though we didn't have
like [__] fentanyl crisis where
everybody was oding but our drugs are
still harder than our parents generation
but not not lethal fentanyl yeah I mean
people did overdose but they were
looking at our generation like we had
crazy drugs we also did have heroin and
cocaine and things like that but a lot
of people didn't mess with it but ours
is lethal now like when a cop goes up to
a trunk and opens it if they stab a
knife into the brick he passes out his
partner passes out it's like a lethal
dose it's insane yeah yeah I saw that
video actually yeah it's it's way
different that's true because then for
the lethal dose back then was like you
had to do a lot now it's like you don't
even have to consume it someone could
like have this clap fentanyl like
[__] two chalkboard erasers that's
like the baby that died at the Airbnb
because there was [__] yeah fentanyl
tracing baby died from fentanyl overdose
what yeah from just an Airbnb having
traces of it on the [__] couch they
put a baby down on the couch and they
got a cook party the night before or
something it's crazy yeah so who gets
seen
but then they I don't think they were
able to they should have sued the
cleaning lady
that [__] didn't clean good so the do
you believe in in uh in the fact of like
I guess like fighting the drug war from
what direction exactly I don't know this
might sound that's tough it's so hard
but I think extreme situations call for
Extreme Measures right yeah but the
thing is like if you don't trust the
state then it's difficult but let's say
we had an honorable state which is
probably never going to happen nope but
if we round up all the people
mandatory rehab
actually [__] went after the drug
lords
and then
try to clean it up hard [__] core
and not be corrupt and like profit off
of it that might be the most effective
method quickly you're just like
literally every point that you just made
is impossible impossible
just just say it just say it just saying
if we had yeah maybe a government that
was a little bit authoritarian when it
came to trying to help Society but then
they pulled back their power once it's
solved and flying unicorns I know man
you know it's you know what's kind of
sad too is I think
and of course like the majority of the
world would hate me for saying this I
think like we have to be honest about
what the comeback rate is for certain
things I agree true because I think like
once you're dumping diarrhea into
someone's head
I don't think you're gonna come back and
be upsetting bro you got to get put down
I gotta get put down I think there's a
point where that's the upsetting thing I
think you're so [__] societally that
like I don't think you're coming out of
that bro and I also think there needs to
be acceptance of reality so like let's
say you're a golden retriever breeder or
whatever you know out of like every
eight or every litter there's like one
that has like I don't know a deformity
or whatever right and that's just part
of it so even like when you're like
let's say when you own a restaurant you
know this much amount of milk is gonna
spoil like it's just part of yeah part
of it so in society we want a hundred
percent of humans to be functional
whatever yeah but maybe statistically
and real realistically 10 are always
going to be like homeless or cuckoo or
whatever then let's I think it's it's
sad to say but maybe that should be okay
and then as long as we keep it close to
10 and then once we get there that's we
achieved our goal versus having this
like dream of let's make it zero but
trying to get to zero we have all these
crazy like non-applicable plans right
and that's that's like when I have
conversations with like my family
members that disagree with me I always
try to put the into perspective the
example of like
everybody understands what it's like to
be in a group project in school and
someone's [__] around and they're not
helping and the attitude is always [__]
that guy kill him I want to pass right
you should be put down but like everyone
knows the feeling of that but then I
think like when it comes to the larger
society suddenly we have a different
mentality of like no let's help everyone
but when it was four people you were
okay with three out of four making it
and that guy just [__] that guy because
you don't want him to take you down your
whole effort right I think uh
intelligent prosperous Society though
should take care of their weak weakest
but also they need to the weakest also
needs to show accountability so for
example if they're like mentally
disabled to the point where they can't
because they're just you know a
three-year-old in their head right then
we should have the social services that
takes care of that if we can like
because we're the richest nation in the
world we should be able to afford it we
can do it right but then
what's [__] up about the states is
that let's say you have a drug problem
let's say your um you're generationally
on welfare or whatever there's no system
of helping them get out of that and then
it's perpetuated it's continued right
there's no end to it there is none there
is there's no end and there's no
accountability so like there's no
program of like Hey we're helping you
out here but you also have to go to
school or you have to do this it's just
[__] hey don't worry about it the
state will take care of you and I think
that's what's [__] up and then there's
also no resources for them like let's
say they're such a huge drastic
difference between a poor community in
America and a well-to-do community
America right the public school system
is not standardized like some states are
as bad as a third world country and some
states are like [__] Elite as hell so
that's where I think it's not
standardized to the point where like the
education that I'm getting growing up is
completely different from yours and I
think as a nation it should probably be
pretty similar so then they have a
Fighting Chance of like having a decent
life and I think all these things is
like how do you even create that because
there's other countries that can do it
and the population there have a really
small crime rate very low poverty all
this stuff right like Scandinavian
countries like when they have drug
problems they have a really good
rehabilitation program for criminals so
I'm like how come they can achieve it
but we're so bad at it I don't know yeah
no nobody really cares it doesn't make
money that's what it is I just feel like
in this world we just gotta survive
make dying illegal you die when it's
your time but I feel like there's so
much like people always want to do this
people always want to do that but no
one's going to do it that's the I think
the funniest irony is the fact that you
you have let's say you have a guy who's
been an [__] his whole life and he
has a crazy ass criminal record he's
molested people he's harassed people all
the way up to that point people want to
save him and then you have a guy who's
like an actor and he's highly successful
and then maybe he got in trouble once
and he made someone uncomfortable they
want him to be homeless damn man why do
you [__] win what is that yeah that's
the part I don't understand that is
really weird how it works I love seeing
people fall yeah and then they love
putting resources into helping people
that don't help themselves and it's like
a little bit like the dichotomy that in
this state because they don't have to
help the guy exactly you know it's like
the sentiment of yeah let's help this
dude is is all good and well but if you
actually have to go to his house and
help them like you know
do stuff and help them clean maybe
that's the thing man is like they're not
the people that are making the decisions
aren't living in the community with
homeless people yeah so it's like I
don't know have you heard of limousine
liberal no so it's like you're hella
balling and you're all for all these
like human rights and like minority
rights and whatever but you live in a
nice gated white community and you have
all this guilt and you're just make
you're just like yeah homeless we got to
do this and that and but you don't even
live among the homeless so their policy
ends up hurting the communities that the
homeless people live in which is usually
minority communities and they're like
what the [__] man you guys made all
these laws and [__] that's like because
you have white guilt or whatever and
then now we have to deal with all the
[__] policies that you created and
I'm like that makes a lot of sense
it's like the whole thing about they
that they're like oh we don't need guns
we don't need guns it goes yeah cause
you live in a gated community with the
armed guards protecting your gated
community but in our neighborhoods we
gotta protect our own homes and [__] and
it's like you're making all these
anti-gun laws and [__] but then now I
can't own it and protect myself from the
robbers down the block from me it's like
Zuckerberg donating Millions to defund
the police but then he has like armed
security all the time yeah
so I'm like that's probably what's
happening too in California like you
just got these different communities
that are isolated and they're like oh
poor homeless people we got to do
something so it comes from this like
good place but they don't really do the
work to understand the comedy is that
you speaking about that they people
would hear that and want you to be
homeless and then once you're homeless
they want you to have a home
it's the weirdest like slingshot it
doesn't make anything you could be
homeless then they're like you should
have a home we should help right now
yeah it's like they want you to hit hit
rock bottom so that you can be exalted
it made it when I do have a home and I'm
like doing well for myself then they're
like why are you so rich yeah yeah once
your home
I want you homeless again exactly that's
what we need to get rid of that Homeless
division
oh
[Music]